7,99 sur dix c'est une note honorable
mais qui malheureusement ne suffit pas à
la france pour obtenir le titre de
démocratie complète pour ça il aurait
fallu un petit centième de point de plus
dommage l'hexagone reste donc encore en
2021 une démocratie défaillantes selon
cette étude de l'economist intelligence
unit la division recherche et analyse du
quotidien britannique l'économiste alors
cette note globale repose sur un
ensemble de critères divers la tenue
d'élections libres et non faussée la
possibilité pour les citoyens de former
librement des organisations politiques
ou civique la confiance dans le
gouvernement la laïcité lusage au nom de
la torture etc etc soixante éléments qui
valu à la france d'être rangé au 22e
rang de ce classement d'une façon plus
générale selon l'étude la démocratie
reculé dans le monde en 2021 la note
moyenne est passée de 5,37 à
5,28 la plus forte chute en une décennie
et une partie de ce recul s'explique
évidemment en france comme ailleurs par
l'instauration de mesures coercitives
destiné à lutter contre la pandémie
certains gouvernements de démocratie
développée réserve un traitement
punitifs aux personnes qui refusent de
se faire vacciner en leur refusant
l'accès aux lieux publics
certaines de ces mesures peuvent être
imposées pour une durée limitée mais
elle constitue néanmoins un précédent en
termes de redéfinition des droits des
citoyens libres de participer à la
société sur un pied d'égalité
le concept d'égalité des droits qui est
le fondement moral de la démocratie
semble être en danger au final cette
étude ne fait que confirmer une
impression déjà partagé par une partie
de la population française selon une
enquête d'opinion de harris interactive
paru en décembre dernier 46% des sondés
estiment que la démocratie française est
grippé sondés dont les trois-quarts
plébiscite par ailleurs la
comptabilisation du vote blanc un
recours plus fréquent au référendum ou
encore l'instauration du fameux ricky le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne une
proposition d gilet jaune rejetée par
emmanuel macron en 2019 on peut aussi
rappeler la colère de certains élus
députés et sénateurs qui ont dénoncé au
cours des derniers mois une
transformation du parlement ans 1 le
chambre d'enregistrement des décisions
de l'exécutif comme lors de l'adoption
des passes sanitaires et vaccinales
exécutif dont les pouvoirs ont été
élargis avec l'état d'urgence sanitaire
on peut enfin citer les abstention
record au scrutin de ces dernières
années près de 67% au premier tour des
régionales et départementales de juin
2021 un record pour des élections dans
la vème république sans compter la très
faible participation aux municipales de
l'année précédente une indifférence
croissante pour le sacro-saint processus
démocratique qui en dit long du coup on
en vient même à s'étonner que la
démocratie française est obtenu une note
aussi élevé